if it doesn't work it's okay we'll
support them again on their next try
and in doing so by transferring that
risk off them to us
we think will lead to a lot more
breakthroughs in the world
[Music]
all right jordan blascheck how are you
i'm fantastic
thanks thanks for uh for having me on i
already enjoyed so much
you know speaking before this so i'm so
excited for the show and i purposely
didn't ask too much because
i'm ready to hear now jordan you have
such an extraordinary life path from
being an infantry officer to studying at
princeton yale and stanford
you know law degree and business degree
and i i can't even
grasp my mind over it you're writing a
book which
is coming out soon but actually by the
time this has aired it will already be
out
and talking about america and the
polarization or hopefully
i hope there's some optimistic note
we'll see and uh and now it's
mid futures and i can't wait to hear all
about that and lastly
venture partner at j ventures and where
i'm also at so this is just all
wonderful jordan
how do you get to go to these three
incredible institutions how do you get
to be an infantry officer
in the u in the u.s army um yeah well
it's it's funny you say that i
every time i talk to israelis i feel
like uh i am so under accomplished
because
by the time you guys even go to school
you've already
done so much in your lives and uh that's
true for you too
um uh but yeah i know i i've had a great
few years
um you and i shared a lot i i was i was
the first
associate at j ventures uh when it when
it was just jay angels
and uh uh it was one of the best
experiences i've had at stanford
and i have huge issues to fill right now
this is very scary
no no you you're far surpassed me
already um
but uh i guess i guess so my my journey
uh started uh back in california
i grew up in los angeles uh son of two
jewish parents who wanted nothing more
than for me to go to medical school
and i get to college i sort of
like a good jewish boy decide i'm gonna
go to medical school and
my junior summer i was working in
medical clinics in india
and just realized that i actually didn't
love the medicine side but i really did
love
being out in austere environments and
working with local populations
and so i decided coming out of that that
i wanted to join the us military
and after looking around i found that
the marine corps was
uh the group that i just i really wanted
to be a part of they they have such
amazing esprit de corps
uh every marine is so proud to be a
marine
for many jordan which of the three
institutions was your undergrad
oh i went to princeton undergrad so
princeton how
common is it for somebody at princeton
during their studies to decide that
they're going to
join the us army um
i think my year we we had about five of
us who who all joined the military
more than i thought okay interesting
yeah you know it was around 2009 and at
that point we had watched all these
generations go off to war
and i think there was a sense among a
lot of us and this was true across my
officer cohort
uh that there were a lot of people who
were just very inspired over
over the couple years before and and so
we were all very
passionate about serving the country uh
we were very idealistic about it
and uh so there was there's a good
number who went um
and uh so i ended up joining the marines
in 2009
i went through officer training and by
the end decided i wanted to be an
infantry officer so i went
i went to the infantry officer course
and then ended up doing two deployments
one to the horn of africa doing counter
piracy and counter-terror missions
and then another to afghanistan where i
was an adviser to the afghan army
oh my god okay i need one short story i
know it's i know it's impossible to just
ask for one but i need
you know one story whether it was from
the officer's training or from one of
your deployments something that taught
you
something that you're taking with you
until now that's always the the fun
the most fun oh that's that's a great
that's a great question
uh you know i i think the the lesson i
learned
uh uh from officer training especially
the infantry officer course
uh the marine corps does a fantastic job
of training young leaders
and the one thing they want you to learn
is to operate under uncertainty
um and so the infantry officer course
kind of from start to finish
is just one uh one uncertain event after
another they'll wake you up
uh kind of at three a.m and send you off
on missions or they won't tell you
what's coming three hours later
and i think the value i gained from that
over time which just being very
comfortable without
knowing kind of what's coming next and
in every job i've had since
uh it's just been very valuable to to
know that through persistence i could
just figure it out
and to be able to make decisions under
uncertainty
um and the marine corps just did a
fantastic job for training that
unbelievable i remember i was i climbed
kilimanjaro with my father and brother
um about a year ago exactly and on the
climb i read extreme leadership
and by by two by two people that were
very high in the ranks and
in the us army and i remember just how
how impressed i was with this mindset
and obviously you know having gone
through a military training of my own i
don't think it was as
intense and probably a little much much
less intense than what you've
experienced
i was much more you know in the typing
my finger got injured that was
the biggest injury i've i had and but
but no but that's incredible okay so
so you do that and and where do you go
from there how do you how do you get
them to
to get to do law in the yale and then
business at stanford
yeah so around uh 20 2013
um it was sort of increasingly obvious
to a lot of us that the wars were
winding down
and if the wars were winding down um at
least for me
it it sort of uh began to lose a bit of
its of its
uh idealistic purpose and so if the wars
weren't going to be there
uh i decided it was time to move on and
it didn't come from
you know a desire for combat but it came
from the sense that you know there's a
lot of mission
and purpose when when we were preparing
for war and uh if we weren't doing that
it wasn't gonna feel quite as
uh visceral and uh little did i know
that
a year later we'd be back at war with
isis um
but either way i made my decision and
decided to
uh to leave and so i wanted to go to
graduate school
um i knew that over the long term i
wanted to do two things in my life
i wanted to be able to kind of engage in
the world of ideas and policy
and i also wanted to start companies and
and so i decided
with four years of the gi bill uh that
it would pay for school
that i would try to do law and business
because law would give me that
ability to work in the world of ideas
and policy and
uh business school would would kind of
help train me for
uh for a career in the private sector
and creating companies
and you know honestly i think there's
something about veterans who come out of
out of the military and feel that the
the world outside the military is so
forward foreign
uh we don't really know what's happening
uh out there so we decide to go to grad
school
um or to go to college and i've seen
that through uh a lot of my friends
leaving the military that there's almost
this desire to kind of like
arm up with degrees because it's it's
going to
world afterwards uh and so i ended up
doing that and getting the two joint
degrees
i think that's that's so interesting you
know in the israeli military
you know every day you see one of your
friends getting released because
everybody is in the military and there's
always this initial shock where you ask
them on the day that they're about to
leave their the base
like how are you feeling are you excited
and almost all of them are saying no
we're terrified we're excited
that we're finished but we're terrified
and then you meet them the next week at
a coffee shop in tel aviv
and they're having the time of their
lives already working on their second
startup
and you know and the assimilation is is
quick because i think everybody goes
through the experience
so they're able to talk to a lot a lot
of people who've gone through this
so you get your your law and your
business degree you also are an
associate
at dave interest and i'd love to touch
upon this book that by the time this
eras has already come out
because it's touching on something that
i became very passionate about studying
with larry dave
larry diamond at stanford this year
talking about the polarization within
the united states
how do you go then because you've done
this in the past just two years right
writing the book
so what what drives you to go and think
critically about
community within the us and and where
we're at now
yeah and you know so i i started this
while i was
at uh stanford business school and it
was also at the same time i started
working for j
ventures and i started working for eric
schmidt at schmidt futures
and i i think to your point before um
leaving the military i felt like i
needed to go to school i needed to get
some credentials and
kind of arm up with more information but
very quickly realized that at that stage
in my life
that the best information i would get
would actually come from
working and and kind of going out and
experiencing things and learning on the
job
and so by the time i got to stanford i
uh
focused mostly externally and was trying
to find opportunities
where i can learn the skills i really
wanted to learn and with j
ventures i got to learn about you know
what it looks like to do due diligence
on companies and how to think about
uh you know the markets they're moving
into and how to
kind of look at a team and evaluate
whether you want to make a bet on
on this group um with eric schmidt i
learned some incredible lessons about
how to think about um things that scale
or how to take ideas from good to great
or collaborate with different groups of
people
and uh you know separately this was
around 2016 and clearly something was
happening in the country there was
a lot of division and um uh the country
seemed to be convulsing under this
uh uh weird political environment and
i decided i wanted to see it firsthand
so instead of kind of learning about it
through
the news or in classrooms i wanted to
see it on the ground
and so you go you go and you get into a
car and you just drive
yeah and the first few trips started
just for fun
uh my friend and i wanted to be on the
road and so we
uh we took some of our our breaks and
and
picked a few places we wanted to visit
and just got out on the road
and while we're out there you just see
the country differently
it's um it's big and beautiful and
everyone you meet is hospitable
uh and you learn something from them and
we also learn from each other
and being in a car for long hours uh
my my friend chris is a is a hippie from
berkeley
i'm a conservative marine and we had
such different world views
but over long conversations uh we were
able to kind of untangle
all these uh common values that that we
actually had underneath it all uh even
if
you know if we were just having a debate
with with friends
um we would seem to be at odds on
everything uh when we were really
able to give it time and with humility
uh we found that we shared all these
common values
and where we didn't we learned something
about ourselves we learned what blind
spots we had or what presuppositions we
were coming to arguments with
and so the heart of our story ended up
being kind of the
the things we learned about each other
and our friendship and the things we
learned about the country through the
people we met
uh and so the book is this argument for
what still binds us together despite all
the political division today
i think that is so that that's so
wonderful and it's
so optimistic one of the incredible
things that i was so inspired by
learning this year with larry diamond
was this experiment in one america in
one room he had where he brought in
hundreds of people with from a random
group
um into it to texas to a hotel
and into a venue and over three days
they they had them
you know converse in a very humane way
and all of a sudden
what what inspired me most was not that
they changed beliefs sometimes but that
democrats began seeing republicans as
instead of
enemies as people that they can converse
with and have some common ground with
and
and same vice versa and and that i mean
that that was the
the hopeful message here and that's why
i'm really really looking forward to
reading the book
but jordan i want to talk about
schmidt's venture that teachers
because one of the things that that i
saw is that you're you're very into
impact investing right and and eric also
all the way back from innovation
endeavors is all about
investing and looking at things that are
moving the needle
what what is impact for you and and why
why are you following that round
yeah it's a great question so for for me
there are things i care about i care
about kind of the the future of america
and i want to see it healthy that that's
a lot of where the book came from
and i care a lot about the future of
security
and uh creating more kind of vibrant
prosperous world free of war
um in you know i think some of that
drove my desire to go into the military
and um you know ultimately i i think
uh the ability for a free democratic
society to
survive depends on progress we we need
to keep growing the pie
if if if people feel like the pie is
shrinking if people feel like we're
static
then it becomes very zero-sum and it's
very hard for
our democratic systems to survive in
that kind of world and so
there is this imperative for us to drive
progress and that's progress in the
fields of science
uh in technology it's progress in our
understanding of human rights and civil
rights
and that's what we do at schmidt futures
we we look to advance
um uh scientific frontiers we try to
advance
uh technology's impact on society and we
try to advance shared prosperity and
national security
um and we've taken a sort of unique
approach um
and we're very lucky to have eric uh
schmidt as our founder
who believes deeply in this and he
pushes us
not to think necessarily about returns
uh but to think about the talent we're
backing
and how we're transferring risk from
them to us and so
his theory and our theory is that the
way to achieve progress
is to go find exceptional people who
don't have a track record yet
and because they don't have a track
record others are really willing to
invest in them
um so venture capital firms won't invest
on kind of the riskiest
uh ideas because they're not proven out
in the market yet
uh government won't invest in sort of
very high risk
research and development because they're
using taxpayer dollars um and so these
ideas or people that don't yet have
track records
have a hard time getting the capital to
test their ideas
and so what we do is we try to look for
those uh exceptional people
people who um you know but for our
investment they wouldn't be able to do
uh or try the thing they want to try and
then we make bets on them and we give
them risk capital
uh we don't take any equity from it um
it is it is purely for the the impact
they could create and then we try to
support them through
uh helping build teams around them
giving them support and mentorship
and watching as you know through uh
through teams and talent uh and support
they
uh achieve their breakthroughs and if it
doesn't work it's okay
we'll support them again on their next
try and in doing so by transferring that
risk
off them to us we think will lead to a
lot more breakthroughs in the world
wow okay so i mean the you know the idea
of a venture capital is that you invest
in
let's say 10 companies a year hopefully
one of them will return
10x and then you're balancing out and
you're able to continue doing that
when you're giving risk-free capital at
risk capital
for no equity or essentially i mean
you're just diluting the the same
pie that you had initially with that
without putting in more so so it sounds
like you have to even be more risk
averse
as you're going through your journey
than you know in in
in traditional venture capital and
you're betting on people you're betting
on talent
how do you go about doing that i mean
you're i mean so
and what does that mean to be head of
talent within schmidt futures
yeah it's a great question so um as head
of talent i oversee
all of our internal talent development
so uh you know because we want to bet on
talent we also think internally we have
to have the best team
i'm responsible for kind of recruiting
everyone we have
and then we have a number of talent
programs so we have an entrepreneur in
residence program
we have a science fellows program an apm
program all of these are designed to go
find
exceptional people and channel them into
certain areas that we think
are underrepresented with that kind of
talent
so for instance our science fellows
program is trying to produce more
interdisciplinary scientists we don't
think there's enough of those
even though all the breakthroughs we're
going to see in the next few decades
are going to come at the intersection of
fields when you combine
things like computer science in biology
that you get kind of these interesting
breakers
and so our program is designed to do
that um similarly we don't think there's
enough
uh computer scientists in the
philanthropic world and so our apm
program is designed to take computer
scientists
and then put them on moonshot type
ventures in the philanthropy world
and so i oversee all those talent
programs and
you know i think the reality is um no
one has really cracked the code on how
you can
rigorously test for talent uh there's
there's still somewhat of an art to this
and everyone on our team has kind of
developed their own methods for how you
find that
and uh you know for some people it's um
they have
almost like archetypes in their head you
know just like in hollywood there's like
specific roles in movies that you look
for um
we think in in the talent world there
are specific archetypes that if you find
them
they're really worth kind of uh uh
betting on
um and so you know there's there's sort
of the genius generative type
who uh you know they just see targets
differently
and and as a result they're constantly
coming up with new ideas
but that person might be terrible at
managing a team and so if we can find
that genius
and then pair them with a highly
talented operator
someone who just you know kind of um
kind of like the chief of staff type
function in the military
they just know how to execute then
that's like a dynamo
uh combination and so a lot of a lot of
what our team does is try to find
those different archetypes or try to
find ways of testing for
for genius or generative ability and
then finding the right pair so that you
maximize their potential
uh impact wow okay that's just
i mean it to me it sounds like a dream
job i mean sitting there and trying to
think
how can we bet on on moonshot ideas by
moonshot people
that are that have that you know are
that have a chance to succeed in this
and we want to join their journey and
support them
and doing that without you know taking
equity without thinking about the
capital side of things but
but embracing the talent they have and
trying to and at the end making a
positive impact on democracy and
i think that's just incredible jordan
what excites you most you mean you're
seeing so
so so many different talents and you're
seeing so many different projects you're
constantly
embracing this idea of moonshot and
impact investing
what what do you get most excited about
yeah so i
i get really excited when i find someone
who
has this incredible combination of just
raw talent
they're very talented they care deeply
about an issue
and they have the specific skill set and
uh
unique insight to go solve it and the
reason i get so excited about that is
it's actually really rare
it's very very rare to find someone who
just they care so much about an issue
and they've they've really figured out a
specific insight
into how you could solve it and they
happen to have the right skill set
in order to do it and when you find that
person it's like unlocking
uh a code that just can can change the
game
and we've found a few of those at
schmidt futures and it's it's like the
greatest
joy to find that person and then get to
help them do what it whatever it is
they're gonna do
because the amount of change and impact
they have is so fast and so quick
once once they get the support they need
um and so i
yeah i i get really excited about that
uh there's one person in particular
who i always love to talk about her name
is clem jacoby who was a google pm
and became obsessed with the criminal
justice system because her uncle had
gone to prison multiple times
and she had this insight into how you
can change the criminal justice system
and she's gonna do it and with a very
small check from us
she's now raised over 10 million dollars
she's operating in all 50 states
and she will she will change the
criminal justice system in the us
and that that all happened in one year
like in one year she
she did that so that that's what i get
excited about
wow and how long is usually this process
as you're meeting new people and as
you're hearing about their talents and
and you know you're not you're actually
forming a much more meaningful
relationship about that person not just
about the
you know how good is the market and what
are the likely returns you're putting
that's
that effort that a vc might put and
you're navigating it towards that person
and their motivation and their abilities
so how long does that usually take you
um it it
it varies by person and it varies on the
kind of person we're betting on but
uh you know someone like clem um it was
almost immediate that
uh we realized like this person's
special let
let's let's see what she can do and so
often we'll start with a smaller check
um just to test them to see you know
with a little bit of money what could
they do
and if if they're able to get some
traction and and
show us that they really have uh the
ability to do whatever it is they say
they want to do
then we'll go bigger on them and so that
first check could be within
a couple weeks of meeting the person wow
jordan it sounds like a dream job
definitely wait for my resume one day
and i and
i that i want to come and and thank you
and and learn as much as i can
and but before we leave and i can't
believe 20 minutes from myself i have so
many more questions to ask you this is
so bad
i need three words from you and then i
have one more question that i'm gonna
have to to squeeze in there
i need three words of uses for yourself
three words to describe myself
yes oh interesting it's the hardest
question out of all of them
that is very hard um okay i'll go with
um
uh persistent freckly i have a lot of
freckles you might not be able to see
them
and uh patriotic i love it i love it i
love it i love it okay the last question
and this is actually gonna be my
favorite one
leadership you've seen leadership across
academia across military across
venture capital what what's a common
theme
what what what is something that you see
that keeps coming up no matter where you
are in the world no matter what you do
because i know i
i'm guided by this idea that leadership
isn't when you're in the boardroom it's
not when you're in front of your
your companies it's everywhere you walk
every move you do
you need to act as a leader and you need
to think of yourself as a leader but so
what are common themes that you're
saying
yeah i mean to me the the the most
important leadership quality and the
most consistent one i've seen in great
leaders
is they just genuinely care about the
people under their command
or under their charge uh they just they
truly love them and they'll do anything
for them
and leaders who have that quality uh
they end up putting more time
and effort into the things they do
because it comes from that place of care
um and people feel it you know you can
feel when someone
genuinely cares about your well-being
and your future and the best leaders do
that
and they do it just because that's who
they are i love it
jordan thank you very very much this was
inspiring and i look forward to continue
learning from you
and reading your book and maintaining
this relationship this was wonderful
this was and uh uh it was my pleasure
thanks so much for having me
thank you take care bye-bye
you